hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
this is a message directly to the bbc
because they are doing yet another
documentary i don't know if it's going
to be about me this time but here's the
thing
they have exposed themself
probably by mistake last week and to be
honest i am
absolutely baffled mind-blown
at sea what i'm about to reveal to you
is shocking because when i
read that post the bbc's post last week
when they're trying to do their
undercover investigations
and they exposed themselves i thought it
was really interesting because they did
a show about me the bbc
i did a whole video about this and this
was in january so about eight months ago
and to be honest when they did the show
i thought this is such bad reporting
i just can't understand how this has
happened have they deliberately
come in with an agenda they must have
done but i found it really strange
because i always grew up thinking
the bbc were fair we're neutral and i
thought they would always
put both sides across and i just thought
they never spoke to me beforehand
they out of all of my thousands and
thousands of students
they chose two unhappy students and i'm
like this is
crazy why and how has this happened well
folks
now i know and bbc to be honest i know
you've always ignored me in the past i
know you've not responded to my previous
video i asked you a ton of questions but
i really think
that the public as we pay so much money
to you bbc as you force everybody
in the country pretty much to contribute
to your journalism
and to your reporting skills and in the
disguise of putting together a balanced
fair view to inform people
i think you really have a lot of
explaining to do
after last week's post so just to set a
little bit of background
the bbc are doing yet another
documentary
on training companies that teach money
so not many companies teach money you
grow up all through school and you do
not learn about money you go to
university you do not learn about money
but the businesses such as my business
that teach people how to invest and how
to make money
have been absolutely penalized by the
media
over the last six eight months and it's
almost like they're trying to stop
people
wanting to become financially illiterate
and i'll talk about that later
but rather than posting and saying hey
we're looking to do a documentary on
people
on people that have gone through wealth
creation courses
property investment training courses can
you come and get in touch if you've had
an experience
they don't say that what they say is
they say please get in touch if
you've had a bad experience
i mean that is absolutely crazy
imagine if i said i'm doing a
documentary on universities
i'm doing and to see whether
universities are good or not
please could you get in touch with me if
you've been through university and you
were left unhappy would that not
make me look like a complete amateur
that had an agenda and my agenda is
clearly
just to speak to unhappy people i mean
it's absolutely insane
they have completely exposed their
agenda and you might say
yeah samuel whatever samuel you've got
your own agenda or saying
but just re read what they posted this
was on linkedin
three days ago bbc business is looking
into online training courses that claim
to offer a fast track to
financial independence but actually
provide little value for money
okay have you spent hundreds or even
thousands of pounds on these courses
but now feel the training didn't match
up to the promises you were made
if this is something that has impacted
you we would like to hear your story
comment below if you're happy for us to
contact you
so so they're not saying contact us if
you're happy contact us if you've been
through the training
we only want to hear from you if you're
unhappy
and the bbc i started running some
online training courses over lockdown
and we've had thousands and thousands
of students come through the online
training and we have had
a tiny fraction i think we've only had
five people that have said actually
contacted them and said they weren't
happy
out of thousands and what the bbc are
trying to do is they're trying to find
those five
they're trying to find those five
because it's very easy to see you look
on my youtube channel you see
every single week people becoming
financially free it's very easy you go
on
my review site and you see thousands of
reviews
and most of the time these are five out
of five
but what they're doing is they're
specifically targeting the unhappy ones
to paint a narrative how shocking is
that and then people
have commented under the post and said i
had an unhappy experience
or i've i've got some experience with
these training companies and they
weren't good
christopher p who is running this and
producing the show
says i'd love you to add me on linkedin
so we can chat and i can hear your
experience
however interestingly when i tried to
add christopher p
on linkedin it's been three days
christopher p i'm still
waiting for your acceptance why do you
not want to speak to me
why do you not want to speak to any of
my happy customers
or any happy customers that have gone
through this at all let me tell you
something
i don't know exactly what the agenda is
maybe they're just trying to create bad
news stories but there is a reason
that the bbc want to get a particular
message across to you
and want to put you off and you scared
of becoming financially literate
the rich are getting richer the poor are
getting poorer and there's a reason that
we don't teach kids about money in
school
and there's a reason that anybody that
starts teaching about wealth gets
shut down and you know what i'd love to
know what the answer is so bbc
if you're doing a documentary about
online training and wealth creation
i run the biggest wealth creation
company in the uk
so why don't we have a conversation and
i can give you anything you need without
you having to do your little narrative
and and try and fish for those five
unhappy customers oh by the way
if you've been through my training
you've been through my online training
courses
why don't you add christopher p on
linkedin and tell him
your experience if it's good or if it's
bad it doesn't matter just
tell him your experience because i think
it's unfair and i don't think it's right
that the bbc are only looking for
unhappy customers so add christopher p
on linkedin
telling your experience bad or good
and tell them the truth and if you
haven't done any training and you're
like well i don't even know what the
situation is
it just shows you cannot listen to the
media because the media have a
very hard agenda so you need to
make up your own mind anyway i just
wanted to get this out there christopher
p
i hope to hear from you also that last
lady abby jayola they did a whole show
about me
and you did a documentary about me i'm
still waiting for you to respond to my
questions
why don't we do a financial freedom
challenge together and you can spend a
week with me
you can even bring your cameras and then
you can see actually how this works and
if it's possible or not
or you can just carry on making up
stories for a living i don't know
but to be honest i think this needs to
stop i think as the bbc
spend i think i read somewhere they
spend 100 million a year on advertising
so they're spending a hundred million a
year to advertise
they're taking everybody's money from
the country
but they're forcing and i mean some i've
heard some people call them now the
british brainwashing channel and i used
to think that's offensive and that's not
fair
how can you say that about the bbc to be
honest bbc i'm beginning to lose faith
in you right now so get in touch
let's have a conversation thanks for
watching add christopher p
tell him what you think subscribe smash
the like button tell me what you think
in the comments
what do you think make up your mind bbc
look forward to hearing from you